although I'm not sure he loves Thailand  as much as me because we were in  Thailand during the Magnus match and the  match was over early because Magnus did  well  and Daniel we're at the hotel for  another week was booked till  the tie break  then he just went back after a day or  two  wow  that's surprising it was a nice hotel so  it must must have been the company I  think  maybe he just missed a katarinburg  let's suppose  as for the game he probably missed that  The Rook can be captured on A7  is broken he was up on the clock as well  that's the biggest blunder of the match  so far like he hung this other Rock but  that was easy to miss some time scramble  Rook A7 is a tough one